my name is Michael Lynch and this talk
is called why good developers write bad
tests so there's the answer my whole
talk is just these two bullet points so
for the next 30 minutes we can take a
nap or something now you probably need
some more convincing
so all of you in this room are good
developers because you're here at high
Texas you're expanding your skills
you're you're willing to hear a talk
from a new speaker who right off the bat
accuses you of writing bad tests so a
problem that a lot of us have is that we
learn a lot of these good practices in
production code like we learn to
refactor our code to eliminate
redundancy we learn to write these small
tightly scoped functions and so we've
been told they're they're good practices
and in fact we're told that they're the
best practices and so when it comes time
to write tests we don't really question
them because why would you question the
best practices we just keep using them
but you know in a lot of cases applying
these these best practices from
production code actually leads to worse
test code and throughout this talk I
want to give you a few examples of how
that can happen so before we get any
further just to clarify on semantics I'm
going to be talking mostly about unit
tests a lot of these techniques will
apply to various kinds of testing they
apply best to unit tests but they apply
to others in general we're gonna keep
talking about unit tests just to keep
things concrete and so unit tests as as
Andy talked about yesterday they're
tests at the smallest level of
granularity so your your testing that a
particular function is correct so if we
if we had a function called Fahrenheit
to Celsius here's a simple unit test
you'd pass it two inch 12 degrees
Fahrenheit and we expect that the answer
is a hundred degrees Celsius and so if
if this is ever not true it means that
something drastic has happened in the
world of standard measurements or more
likely you broke your code and you need
to fix it and so here's an example of an
anti-pattern I see a lot with people who
are really good at writing code but not
too experienced at writing test code so
we're just going to walk through it
we're testing this this class called
Account Manager as we're calling self
dot Account Manager get score for the
user Joe 123 we get
initial score and we make sure the
initial score is 115 so there's two big
problems with this right off the bat so
first is where did this Joe 123 account
come from like why why does it count
manager have Joe 123 is this just
hard-coded every single account manager
has a Joe 123 and then similarly why is
Joe 123 score 150 where is that coming
from and so a lot of times when I see a
test like this the developer says oh the
answer is in the setup and so if you
scroll up to the setup and if you're not
familiar setup is the the method that
the unit test framework calls
automatically before every test so our
setup we're creating this mock database
it's got row with Joe 123 with a score
of 150 and it assigns that to the
account manager and so the developer
might say okay so and all the answers
are in the setup and so this is a good
test because everything you need is is
in the setup and in the test function
itself so I think this is actually a bad
test and throughout this talk I'm gonna
explain why so to understand test code
isn't like other code so when we think
about production code it's it's too
complex to read all at once
so we've if you if you had a if every
application was 10 lines of code we
wouldn't need things like functions or
classes or modules you could just you
just write those 10 lines and read them
top to bottom we we invent all these
techniques and these things like
functions and classes to to break large
bodies code into small consumable chunks
and so good production code is well
factored it allows us to think about
these these very complex pieces of code
in in small narrowly scoped pieces and
so the components are in logical chunks
we wreck things into layers of
abstraction where we can understand each
thing in its own layer test code is very
different test code if you think about a
unit test function it basically is its
own tiny application it's very simple it
usually just starts up calls one
function exits but that's its own
application and so in in the case of
test code it is simple enough to read
top to bottom most most unit tests you
could write them in just 10 lines of
code and so you don't need these things
like classes and functions to break up
the complexity
the other thing that's different about
tests is that developers often read
tests in isolation it's not often that
if you if you read a production function
if you read like a member of a class a a
method often you have to read other
parts of that class to understand you
have to you have to read the member
variables you have to read the other
functions that it calls if if you have a
unit test that fails often reading that
unit test and understanding that single
function is enough to understand why it
failed you you generally don't have to
read other functions in that test suite
to understand what went wrong and lastly
test must be correct by inspection we we
have confidence that our production code
is correct
because we have tests that exercise it
you generally don't have tests for your
tests because you would just end up in
this infinite progression where you're
writing tests for everything else
that you're writing and so test the last
line of defense is that is the fact that
you can read it and reason about it and
so a good test code maximizes obvious
Ness it makes it so that you can you can
quickly jump into a unit test if it
fails and understand quickly what it's
asserting and why it's failing currently
and it should minimize cognitive load
the more complex you make your unit test
functions the harder it is for
developers to reason about it the easier
it is for them to overlook bugs that are
in the test function so this said I
don't know if this comes up sort of so
this is I took this in my basement I've
got a raid on remediation system in my
house that sucks air from below the
floor of my basement out above the roof
of my house and it's to make sure I
don't die of radiation radon remediation
or radon poisoning and so it's got a
very interesting unit test in that it's
got a glass tube that's filled with
liquid and the tube is connected by a
straw into the vacuum tube and so I know
that the the vacuum tube is creating
suction because it's sucking the liquid
up to this four mark there and so this
is a very interesting unit test for the
physical world because it's very hard
for it's very obvious when that fails if
it's not reading for if the if I for
example pull out the straw and so that
it's not getting suction the water
recedes to to the zero level and so it's
very hard for there to be a false
negative
it's very hard for the the level to read
for and they're not to be suction so
this is a very good unit test in that
it's very clear it's very hard for
something to go wrong and for me not to
see it and so we see this a lot in the
physical world if you think about
something you've ever done hobby
electronics you probably recognize the
image in the center is a multimeter and
so it's a very simple tool it's just got
these two probes and it lets you
diagnose what's wrong with a circuit
board which is often very complex
there's also like if you look at a
weather vane it's it's a very simple
tool and that it shows you which way the
wind is blowing it just points in the
direction that the wind is blowing and
so the thing about the multimeter is
it's a layer simpler than the thing it's
testing and so this is a good thing to
keep in mind with unit tests as well
because unit tests need to be correct by
inspection so they often need to be at
least one level simpler than the thing
they're testing and with a weather vane
as well like you it's very if you see a
test fail you don't want to worry about
whether the problem is in the test
itself you want to think that should be
as small a possibility as possible and
so weather vane like if if it's pointing
north you have a pretty high confidence
that the wind is blowing north it's very
unusual for a weather vane to point
north when the wind is blowing east and
so you can think about that in your your
unit tests you want to apply those same
principles and so one thing that's very
helpful when you're writing unit tests
is to think about if another developer
comes along when this test fails can
they diagnose what the problem is and so
going back to this unit test we had
before it's very hard for another
developer to understand what's what's
wrong here because they don't have
information about Joe 123 where that's
coming from or why this score is 150 and
so we can solve that by inlining the
setup method I showed you before there
was a separate setup method and we if we
just take the body of that setup and put
it right in the the test function that
solves the problem because we now we
have everything we need to know right in
the test function to use the the reader
doesn't have to scroll up and down and
your unit test file to understand what's
going on and so the other the other
benefit of this is a common pattern in
unit testing is this structure of
arrange act assert so arrange is where
you set up your preconditions act is
where you act on the object under test
in this case is the accountmanager
and assert is where you start
the post conditions are correct and so
if you if you inline your setup in this
way you that you just achieve this this
structure that a lot of people will
recognize quickly and it makes it easier
for them to understand your tests so the
reader should understand your test
without reading any other code that
everything should be right there in the
test function where they can see it
without a lot of scrolling so next I
want to talk about dr why we talked
about this yesterday so dr why is don't
repeat yourself and so we we generally
learn this in production code and it's a
good idea in production code so here's
an example of some production code where
i'm showing you some calls to a sequel
like database and so if a lot of us in
this room saw this code we'd say okay a
lot of this code is redundant so almost
every line and both these functions are
repeated the only thing that's different
is this one segment of a string and so
for a lot of us are factoring like this
looks pretty good we'd say okay we're
we're abstracting away all the things
that are repeated and so get user names
and get user IDs are now just different
by the only thing that's different about
them and so a lot of us looking at this
it's like if this is production code
we're saying okay yeah I like this for
factoring it's fewer lines of code if
you like less redundancy so this is
great and so in the in the unit test I
showed you before right I inline the
setup some of you may be thinking ahead
and saying okay that's fine for that one
function what if you got another
function like test increased score now
you've got these three statements that
are exactly the same and so that that's
a big problem because we know we don't
like redundancy and so here the thing to
keep in mind is that eliminating
redundancy is not a goal in itself you
you eliminate redundancy because it
serves some other goal and so the the
goal you want to keep in mind is
simplicity and obviousness and I think
those two are the most important things
in unit testing and so in this case
where you're making trade-offs either
way so if you do refactor this into a
setup so sure you're you're eliminating
redundancy but you're also increasing
complexity now you're making it so that
the reader has to jump around your your
test file in order to understand the
test and so you're kind of making a
trade-off either way so in my opinion
that
just inlining it's three statements it's
it's not a big deal to inline these
these three statements you add seven
lines it's gonna vary for everybody like
how many lines you're comfortable
repeating but for me like just these
three lines I feel like it gives you a
lot of simplicity and for unit tests I
think that's that's more important so I
think except we're done see if it
supports simplicity and so maybe you'll
you'll indulge me that last thing you'll
say okay three statements I don't mind
doing that but what about when you've
got an object that's really complicated
to instantiate it so imagine account
there's account manager class instead of
just taking this one parameter it takes
three and they're hard to instantiate
too so you've got these like I think
this is like fifteen lines of code and
so you're probably saying like I'm not
gonna copy/paste these 15 lines of code
and every single one of my tests that's
crazy and so I agree that would be crazy
because at 15 lines it's it's taking up
so much of your test function that it
obscures what you're actually trying to
test if a reader comes and tries to
understand what behavior you're trying
to assert they kind of get lost in all
the setup and so you're your initial
instinct might be to refactor this into
helper methods but first you should take
a look at the interface you're using so
in this case so the first parameter is
this user database object okay that
sounds fine that's it's an account
manager that manages users so sure I can
take a user database then the next thing
where it gets kind of weird is taking a
privileged database that's wrapped by
this privilege manager object so already
there's a red flag that it's taking
these two objects that are at different
layer layers of the abstraction and
lastly it takes this URL downloader and
so that's very logically different from
the two previous parameters and so I see
this case a lot where like this the the
class interface is evolved over time
where the parameters don't really make
sense any more and it becomes this this
thing that's very hard to instantiate
and so the problem is if it's difficult
to instantiate in your tests it's also
going to be difficult to instantiate in
production and so the if you're tempted
to write a helper method here you can
refactor your production class and in so
doing you'll improve your tests and
you'll improve your production code and
so yeah so improving your production
code simplifies your tests
when you you find yourself tempted to
write a helper method to make your tests
easier to write think first about if you
can refactor your production code to
make everything easier so sometimes you
just you have no other choice you have
to write a helper method sometimes you
just don't have the luxury of
refactoring the production class because
maybe it's used in two hundred places so
if you do have to write helper methods
you have to make sure you don't commit
the cardinal sin of test helper methods
which is two very critical values in
your test helper and so when I say a
critical value I mean any value that the
reader needs to know in order to
understand why your test is correct and
so I'll give you an example so this is
similar to the tests I showed you before
so here's our test method we've got
account manager and then we we call this
self to add dummy account helper method
and then we we do a just score and
assert equal that the score is 175 and
so here we see the same problem that
I've been showing you where there's
hidden information we don't know why the
the final score is 175 because it
assumes that there's this user 1 Joe 123
and it assumes their score was 150 and
so the helper method it buried these
critical values we needed to know these
values in order to understand why tests
increase score was correct it also
commits a slightly less severe sin but
it there's this call to account manager
add account so you also want to avoid
this it's varying interactions with in
this case account manager is the object
under test and so as much as possible
you want to keep all interactions with
the object under test in the test method
itself it makes it much harder for the
reason reader to understand what you're
doing to the object you're testing if if
you're sprinkling interactions with it
throughout different functions so you
can rewrite this and you can you can
still use a helper method if you just
respect this this law of not varying
critical values so this is the same code
we've we've rewritten it so that we're
still eliminating some boilerplate in
this make dummy account method but you
can see that like all the information we
need is right there we see Joe 123 is
created we see that they start with a
score of 150 and so it's very intuitive
for the reader to follow this we've got
150 plus 25 is 175 so that all makes
sense and so I basically don't
have to show you the helper method but I
can but you see like all it's doing is
eliminating some of the dummy work of
presumably these these parameters to
account our required values and so the
helper method is just a linen
eliminating some of this stuff that's
not relevant to your test so don't bury
critical information in your test helper
methods you want to keep all the
informations the reader needs in the
test itself so now I'll talk about
naming so if you're writing some
production code and you had the choice
between these two function names so user
exists and their account is in good
standing with all bills paid or is
account active so a lot of people in
this room would probably choose the
second one because the the first one is
very precise but you don't want to
burden your team with this super long
function name if this were a Java
conference I think everybody in the
audience would be saying well those both
those names are far too short but it's
by Texas so we value conciseness and so
there's a difference in tests in in
production you don't want to force your
teammates to have to like constantly
write this this super long function name
but in tests you never write calls to
test functions you write out a function
name exactly once when you define the
test because the the test framework
itself is what calls the test function
and so because of that you you concise
instill matters but you can error more
on the side of being more precise and
being for more verbose so here's an
example of a unit test for imagine
you're you're editing this class called
tokenizer and you're editing it and then
you run the unit tests and you see this
test fails and says fail test nest token
failed with empty string is not none so
if you were the person editing tokenizer
you probably wouldn't know why this has
failed and this is a very common naming
pattern I see where people will just
prefix test with the the function that
they're calling in the test and so the
problem here is you're forcing the the
developer to go read the testament a
shinto understand why this test failed
and so if you if you just go crazy with
test function naming you can give a lot
more information so if you were if you
were modifying this class and you
the test fails is test next token
returns none when stream is empty that's
that's very clear it's it's clear that
so you you modify this behavior where
the test expected that when this the
stream parameter is empty then next
token returns none and somehow you broke
that but you can fix that without ever
having to go read the test
implementation and so that should be a
goal of your test name and your test
should be named so well the people can
diagnose failures just by reading the
name of the test that failed is the last
thing I want to talk about magic numbers
so if if you're not familiar our magic
number is a numeric value or string that
appears in code without information
about what it represents so here's an
example of a magic number so we're
calling this function calculatepay and
we're passing it a value of 80 and so we
don't really know what this 80
represents and so we as a developer
community have basically all decided
that magic numbers are evil and so we we
vanquish them whenever we see them and
so a rewrite of that would be we use
named constants so we have a named
constant called hours per week and weeks
per pay period and so anybody reading
this code can understand where this ad
is coming from they don't have to guess
about why the number is 80 and so we're
so used to this in production code that
we've we've brought this practice with
us to test code and so if you if you're
somebody who hates magic numbers this
test looks correct to you so we're not
using any magic numbers we're using name
constants and so this is this is a good
test in that we're not using any magic
numbers and so if you're somebody who's
who's very devoted to getting rid of
magic numbers the next slide might be
kind of shocking to you so brace
yourself so this is the same test with
magic numbers and it's a lot more
readable you can just trace it very
easily 72 eight eighty like that it's
very intuitive it's half the lines of
code and so I think in in tests code
we're used to this idea of eliminating
magic numbers but magic numbers are
actually fine in test code and the the
other issue that was kind of hidden in
the example with named constants is this
line so we have we're calculating
expected billable hours by adding
together starting hours and hours in
and so the problem with this is I said
earlier that we want to like minimize
the level of logic in our test code we
wanna make it as obvious as possible and
so here were it's very simple logic but
it's it's nevertheless logic and the
problem is that in our production code
in our production code there's almost
certainly a line that's almost exactly
like this and I see this a lot people
will take a complex calculation from
production code and basically just
copy-paste the exact same thing into
their tests and so the problem is if
there's an error in that calculation you
you don't know it because you're using
the exact same calculation in both your
production code and your test code and
so if you if you just embrace magic
numbers in your tests you can you can
avoid this and so a lot of the reasons
that we have to to always use named
constants don't really apply and tests
so prefer magic numbers to name
constants in test code so in summary you
want to keep the reader in your test
function you want to make sure they're
they're not jumping all around your test
file to understand why the test function
is correct
redundancy isn't eliminating redundancy
isn't a goal itself you want to accept
redundancy if it makes the tests more
obvious and simpler and you want to if
you're tempted to write helper methods
you should first think about whether you
can refactor your production code to
eliminate the need for helper methods
you want to avoid burying critical
information that you test helpers you
want to make it so that the the reader
can stay in your test function without
having to look outside for this critical
information go crazy with long test
names because you never have to call
your test functions and embrace magic
numbers they're they're your friends you
they're not as evil as they are in
production code and so that's all thanks
to PI Texas for having me in all the
volunteers this is originally a blog
post so if you want to read this as a
blog it's you can just google good
developers bad tests and if you want to
tweet it to everybody and say it's the
best blog post you've ever read that's
totally fine I don't mind I'm on Twitter
I'm at deliberate coder here's my email
if you want to read these slides there
mt lynch page link /gd BTW good
developer bad test and do we have time
for questions so we've got some time for
questions let me have any questions or
want to yell at me for this merging DIY
so the question is how did I decide that
magic numbers are okay and tests yeah
good question
so in in production code it's we we
usually have this problem of we want to
avoid magic numbers in production code
because usually the number we should we
choose are not arbitrary like they
they're usually related to something
else in the production code and so it's
necessary like name constants to
eliminate that problem of if it's
related to some other number the name
constant kind of enforces that
relationship whereas in tests that
doesn't really apply usually you're it's
not related to something else it's not
going to be related to something else in
your tests and the other thing is that
in in tests they're like in in
production code you're you want to show
that the number isn't arbitrary and in
tests then the number often is arbitrary
you're just choosing a number that that
meets a number of value so like you
might want to choose a negative number
to make sure that your function handles
negative numbers and so it could be like
negative five or it could be negative
ten it doesn't really matter you're just
choosing something that's negative and
so the it should be the test name itself
that that tells the reader why what's
special about the magic numbers that
you're choosing but thank you that was a
good question question over there
as classes today not to hold your
functions that are in test cases
yet I mean I I personally use the unit
tests module and in Python so I I read
all my unit tests in in classes and so I
think classes can be a good way of when
when the test fails you also see the
class name and so that can be a helpful
way of giving context of the reader so I
think it's these these aren't hard and
fast rules they're not like never write
tests operas but I think the the idea I
want to get across is that you should be
thinking about like what's gonna help
the reader to understand why the test
fails what's gonna what's gonna make it
obvious to the readers so using using a
test class if it if it makes it easier
for the reader to understand quickly
what the test does and why it's failing
I'd say use whatever tool you can so yep
the question
sure
got a bunch of testicle
I guess I understand the question if
you've got a set up then they would all
fail anyway right
okay yeah I mean I think I guess I
understand what you're saying so if you
have some something where like you
you're breaking all of your tests and
you could maybe avoid that if you you
were better factored yeah I mean for me
I feel like that's fine I'm like if you
if you do something that does break all
of your tests then all of your tests
should break because yeah so I mean but
I think that's a matter of opinion it's
it's kind of kind of debate depend on
what your team thinks and how you feel
about the code so any other questions
Oh question up here surprised nobody's
yelled at me about the dr waa
so we say that you have to have useful
information in the test
do you understand printing that from a
sensitive
so I I think the I think this kind of
goes back to what I said in the
beginning where I think unit tests are
small enough that you don't we use
encapsulation in production code because
there's there's too much code to
understand if you just read it top to
bottom I think often in unit tests you
can't it's there's there's small enough
logic that you could just read it top to
bottom so you you're making a trade-off
so if you use encapsulation to refactor
out some of the redundancy you're
eliminating redundancy but you're you're
now increasing complexity so you're
forcing the reader to go outside your
test function to understand what's
happening and so you know there's
there's no one rule that's gonna answer
it in all cases I think we're engineers
and so part of that is making trade-offs
I think people are are too used to
eliminating redundancy so they just do
it without thinking about it but I think
often it's better to just have the
simplicity of having redundant code but
it appears in every test function so
that the reader can just read a top to
bottom so out of time or more question
right sure
so to me that's still like I I can
appreciate the explicitness of it but I
think you still pay a penalty in forcing
the reader to jump around I think I
think there's tremendous value in
letting the reader just read a test
function from top to bottom without
having to read it another fixture or and
I mean sometimes it's fine if there's
not critical information in the test
picture if it's just all information
yeah I mean it depends yeah it depends
on what your preferences are and one
more question
if you break something in the class
under test and not all of your tests
break you only need to change those
tests it did break it's more explicitly
it's the floor presently these are the
exact things that I broke if you what
you read is in itself effectively
effectively broke all the tests
effectively changed all the tests
without that actually necessary so I'm
like the freaking the dependency getting
rid of the cell okay
[Applause]